[Musica]
questa storia inizia dall altro capo del
mondo
siamo a los alamos in new mexico a los
alamos c'è il più grande centro di
ricerca sulla bomba atomica nel mondo e
proprio dove nasce la bomba atomica
e qui studiano due studenti due ragazzi
un ragazzo bresciano è un ragazzo
portoghese studiano insieme e nel
weekend escono divertirsi
spesso il bresciano luca invita bruno il
portoghese a brescia e qui i due
conoscono una donna e fanno amicizia
nonostante questa donna non sia affatto
portata per la matematica e questa donna
sono io
bruno si trasferisce a new york e e
tutti quanti ci teniamo in contatto con
facebook spesso bruno diventa lui
diventa un data scientist spesso bruno
posta dei post sulla sua attività
scientifica sui suoi libri e un giorno
posta
questo posto dove lui e giudici di gara
ad una gara della nasa e questa gara si
chiama nasa space up challenge e io vedo
brune dico castità ma che bello chissà
che cosa sono questi dati spaziali
chissà se potrò mai partecipare anch'io
una cosa del genere
poi mi immagino degli algoritmi che mi
arrivano addosso e quindi a lontano da
me questa idea però continuo comunque a
seguire bruno perché lui si sacrifica
molto spesso per la scienza si cui
dovreste river e dopo di che succede
questo succede che io vedo questo post
la stessa gara dove bruno è stato
giudice a new york ea vicenza e in
questo posto c'è scritto che tutti
possono partecipare anche chi non è un
ingegnere anche chi non è uno scienziato
tutti possono partecipare ognuno di noi
ha dentro di sé le risorse per salvare
il nostro unico pianeta la terra
questo il discorso del direttore nasa
europa timo titani al kick off di nasa
spesa challenge vicenza
io sono galvanizzata da queste parole io
voglio partecipare nonostante chi mi è
vicino
mi dica questo tu tu non sei un
ingegnere devi stare coi piedi per terra
la nasa tu ma nessuno ti calcolerà mai
e invece succede questo
un produttore di canapa un neo laureato
alla bocconi ed io andiamo alla spesa
challenge e creiamo un progetto per
l'introduzione della canapa come
coltivazione sostenibile per combattere
fame e povertà nella fascia sub
sahariana
la gara è meravigliosa io sono
contentissima ho scoperto un nuovo mondo
e quindi decido mentre torno a casa che
devo assolutamente portare questa gara a
brescia per dare la possibilità anche i
ragazzi bresciani di poter partecipare a
questa gara all'inizio non è semplice
tutti sono esaltati dal nome nasa ma in
realtà nessuno capisce in realtà che
cosa davvero sia però qualcuno in me
aveva creduto e con degli amici
riusciamo a portare nasa space up
challenge a brescia con l'aiuto del
comune di brescia con l'aiuto di
fondazione sm
la gara è un successo nonostante ci
siano pochi partecipanti e alla fine
della gara
mi rendo conto però che c'è qualcosa che
manca
che cos'è la nasa space up challenge è
una gara dove in team si utilizzano i
dati satellitari messi a disposizione da
nasa per creare delle soluzioni e delle
applicazioni che quindi possono essere
utilizzate anche ad uso terrestre e
quindi
dopo questa gara io sento che manca
qualcosa
ed ora vi farò vedere degli oggetti che
cosa hanno in comune tutti gli oggetti
su questo tavolo tutti questi oggetti
compreso il cellulare che avete in tasca
sono di derivazione spaziale cioè la
tecnologia utilizzata per crearli è di
derivazione spaziale questa questa
coperta termica che noi oggi usiamo
quando facciamo un incidente o la
vediamo spesso nei video per i migranti
questa coperta termica è stata inventata
per porre rimedio a un problema nello
spazio
questa coperta è stata inventata per
coibentare un modulo della stazione
spaziale internazionale e noi oggi la
usiamo qua dallo spazio alla terra dall
idea per risolvere un problema spaziale
alla concretezza una famosissima marca
di trapani ha inventato hahn ha
migliorato uno dei suoi trapani
per far sì che potesse crivellare sulla
luna
la tecnologia migliorata in questo modo
ha reso il trapano uno dei best seller
mondiali quello che vedete è una sonda a
ultrasuoni in terra si usa per la
medicina è stata spedita nello spazio e
con i miglioramenti tecnologici ottenuti
oggi in questa sonda si usa per per
scannerizzare i difetti volumetrici
scoprire i difetti volumetrici nei
metalli e questa linea famosa azienda
bresciana
noi non dobbiamo andare lontani per
avere dei degli esempi di tecnologia
spaziale di trasferimento tecnologico
spaziale alle mie spalle vedete questa è
la sala cardiochirurgica della
poliambulanza di brescia il braccio che
vedete è stato creato utilizzando la
tecnologia del braccio che c'è al di
fuori della stazione spaziale e anche
gli screen i touch screen che vedete
sono sempre di derivazione spaziale
tutti questi oggetti
noi possiamo crearli qui a brescia
quello che davvero manca è un luogo dove
questi oggetti le idee della space up
challenge possono diventare realtà e noi
possiamo farlo non sto parlando di
futuro
non sto parlando di astronauti sto
parlando di tecnologia
nella prima guerra mondiale gli aerei
degli alleati arrivavano negli hangar
completamente crivellati c'era un
matematico e disse noi dobbiamo
rinforzare le parti vitali di questi
aerei
ora immaginiamo le nostre aziende le
nostre aziende sono esattamente come
questi aerei vengono crivellate dalla
tarda le tasse dalla burocrazia dal
copit 19 e quello che io vi propongo
oggi è esattamente una soluzione per
rinforzare le parti vitali delle nostre
aziende e le parti vitali delle nostre
aziende sono esattamente la tecnologia e
la ricerca tecnologica
l'italia non so se lo sapete è il terzo
contributore europeo di esa e se
l'agenzia spaziale europea
noi paghiamo con le nostre tasse islam e
abbiamo contribuito come terzo
contributore con 2 miliardi e 282
milioni di euro
questi fondi vengono usati parzialmente
per la ricerca spaziale però vengono
usate anche per un'altra cosa che si
chiama ttp technology transfer programme
chiesa questo technology transfer
programme prevede anche un incubatore un
incubatore dove ci sono fondi per le
aziende le start up e personale tecnico
specializzato per aiutare le aziende le
start up a creare appunto tecnologia di
derivazione spaziale
quindi noi possiamo farlo possiamo usare
questo incubatore per uscire da questa
crisi
quando ero giovane mi hanno promesso un
futuro che non è mai arrivato siamo
stufi di parlare di futuro soprattutto
per quanto riguarda i nostri giovani
il presente dei giovani è un valore
costituzionale è una una cosa troppo
preziosa soprattutto quando si tratta
dei nostri figli
noi ei nostri giovani dobbiamo trovare
il coraggio di essere impazienti
dobbiamo ritrovare di farlo qui ora e
adesso perché questo incubatore questi
incubatori c'è nessuno in tutta europa
in francia ne hanno 15 e e sono molto e
hanno dei benefici con ricadute
economiche importanti nelle regioni che
li ospitano
se l'opportunità non bussa costruisci un
portale per farci atterrare lo spazio
[Applauso]